sometimes it's a guy protagonist just
get the short end of the stick you can
become the strongest being in the planet
with girls swooning over you and at
times you can just be as unfortunate as
Maka though deemed hideous by the
goddess he gets thrown into nowhere as
far from the human civilization as
possible at the very least he still has
immense powers that Captivate the
numerous denizens of the world it's
pretty interesting to see betrayed by a
deity stories like this take a
light-hearted note from the get-go you
already know the tsukimichi is a parody
it's got the fights it's got the tension
but it leans really heavily on the
comedic territory it's got this great
balance between action and comedy
regardless and that's coming from a
studio that doesn't have a lot under
their resume in terms of action shows
tsukimichi is an underrated show that
you should definitely give a try